What do I think about Zazzle?
So I got a great question from one of my
Google + viewers William
(love you guys!) who wrote in to say
“Hello Evan. I would really like to hear your opinion
on Print On Demand websites such as Zazzle and Spreadshirt.
I see a lot of artists and entrepreneurs using their services.
I personally have decided to go down a different path
because for me I feel it’s not the right way to do business.
But I think it would make for an interesting discussion
if you can give your thoughts on it.”
So William, this will be an interesting discussion
unfortunately one-way because… you know
unless you want to make a video response
I’d love to see that.
But I’m actually a fan of Zazzle and I’ll tell you why.
You’re not going to make
millions of dollars selling stuff on Zazzle
okay, but that’s not the point.
The point of Zazzle is to help you get started.
This is why you use Zazzle.
It’s to help you launch your business.
If you’re trying to launch a t-shirt line
okay, say you want to launch a new brand of t-shirts
the way that most entrepreneurs will go about it is
you have to go and buy t-shirts, right.
You have to stock up on inventory.
So you create your design and then you have to go
and get men’s and women’s
from extra small to XXXL
and you’re carrying lots of inventory.
If you’re waiting for an order to come
and then you’re going to go put out that order
right, like some guy comes and says
“Hey, I like that shirt, I want to buy one”
you got to go print one
that’s going to be super expensive for you.
You’re not going to make any money off it.
So the way to make money is to sell a thousand of them
5 thousand of them, 10 thousand of them.
Make that kind of order because then the cost per shirt
comes down to a price where you can make money.
But, this is the big but, the big problem
– it’s that you don’t know which shirt’s going to sell or not.
And so many people take the little money that they have right,
I’m assuming money is important to you
you don’t have a ton of reserves built up
you can’t blow this cash
whatever money you spend has to pay off, right
they blow their money on that first run
that first line, and then it doesn’t sell.
And you’re stuck with all these shirts sitting in your garage.
So why I love Zazzle is because it allows you to test out
your concept without spending any money on it. Right
you may have 20 designs for shirt ideas.
Maybe 2 of them will be amazing
and the other 18 won’t work out
but you don’t know until you test.
You may think they’re all amazing.
You got to see what the market wants too.
So Zazzle allows you to put them online, right.
You put them online, you may make a dollar a shirt
you may make 50 cents a shirt – it doesn’t matter.
What you’re doing is testing the concept
and also building a customer base.
So you put them online
you promote them like you would promote your regular shirts
and you see what does well.
If you can sell a hundred shirts on Zazzle
now you can talk about having justification to go out
and create an order, right
and spend money to buy a thousand shirts
where you can start making some money.
But if you can’t sell a hundred shirts on Zazzle
then why would you go out and order a thousand shirts?
You’re going to lose your money on it.
So I love Zazzle for early stage
for proving concept
for showing that this thing works
that people actually care
that people actually buy your product
and then taking the winning ideas
and going out and launching a line with that.
That’s why I love Zazzle.
Believe.
For those of you watching you like the video,
support me
by clicking the link in the description.
You can leave a comment.
Let me know what you think
or click on my face to subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.